[Music]
you mentioned earlier
that at times you're you're boiling
inside
i certainly have experienced that
personally
now anger how would you distinguish and
and
i sort of intuitively know these
are different but i would struggle to
maybe on the spot
separate the two anger and resentment
because uh
one of your quotes that i
have here in front of me with my notes
is consult your resentment
it is revelatory and i'd love to unpack
i'd like to unpack that
uh but if you could walk us through yeah
well in my new book
i have a chapter which is rule 11
do not allow yourself to become
resentful deceitful or arrogant
it's kind of the evil triad as far as
i've been able to determine
resentment in particular it's bad it's a
it's a bad emotion
it's useful you can learn a lot by
noticing that it occurs
resentment tells you one of two things
um one is that um
you're that someone's treading on your
territory and something needs to be done
about it
or that you need to grow the hell up and
stop complaining and
it's hard it isn't necessarily obvious
when you feel resentful
which of those it is but you need to
figure it out
you know because you can you can harbor
resentment for
for unlived life for for a very very
long period of time
and all it does is corrupt you it hurts
you
it hurts you physically because it's a
stressful emotion anger is a stressful
emotion
because your body hyper prepares for
action if you're angry
because you might get into conflict so
and that's a high
that's a dangerous situation and so you
burn off a lot of psychophysiological
resources
in anger if you're resentful
there's probably something you need to
say there's certainly something you need
to figure out
and so you can you can use it as a guide
to further development
it's very much useful to to aim at a
resentment-free existence
and that means i suppose that you're
taking up enough space
you know you're not there's always a
struggle between your domain and
the domain of other people everyone
competes for everyone else's attention
everyone competes for everyone else's
time
you compete for your own time and if
you're resentful
it's highly probable that well as i said
either you're not standing up for
yourself
sufficiently or someone is legitimately
on your case in which case you well you
need to do something about that
or you know live with the consequences
which
is very unpleasant it's not optimal
sometimes i suppose it's unavoidable
but you know generally there's something
that can be done about it
maybe you need a new job it's easy for
people to think that they're better than
they are
and it's not surprising that everybody
wants to think that
i probably want to think that about me
so then you'll get angry about something
you know maybe your partner puts you
down
in public doesn't show you the respect
maybe you're married saying husband and
wife owe each other
a certain amount of categorical respect
sort of independent of the individual
personalities
you know what if you have decided that
you're going to devote your life to
someone and vice versa
they're now in a category that requires
a certain amount of respect
and to maintain the relationship over
time that's good for your partner and
it's also good for you
maybe you've taken a shot in public and
you're really angry about it
and but you don't notice it because you
want to think that you're better than
you are
that sort of thing doesn't upset you and
so you don't
say anything about it you don't do
anything about it and
then you don't fix it and that's a
mistake it's much better you could say
to your partner look you know we were
out for dinner tonight
and uh you said something snarky which i
didn't think was appropriate now
i might be a hypersensitive um i might
be hypersensitive and touchy and
immature and maybe you hit me in a weak
spot
or maybe you're playing some power game
why don't we figure that out
now that's messy people don't like
conversations like that
and i think that's one of the things
that's peculiar about me
for one i don't know why exactly but i
don't
like that i i won't let those things go
so the peculiarity is that you'll you'll
open those conversations you don't have
an aversion to it
well i have a horrible adversion to it
and i don't like
conflict but i've learned and i this is
partly i suppose clinical training but
it's not just that
some things if you don't address them
they just get worse
and i've i've been able to see where
things are going to go it's kind of like
what i mentioned to you earlier that if
i watch someone
i can generally figure out what they're
up to
i also can see where things are going
and
so you know if if if i walk into
someone's house and
there are things out of order in a
particular way
if i pay attention to that that's in
that's often indicative of something
not right in the relationship you know
maybe the kitchen's a mess
it's like there's no there's food that
isn't
fresh in the fridge for example or or
there's packages
up in shelves that haven't been opened
for like two years
or since the wedding let's say um
that's too much chaos in the kitchen
something's wrong well what's wrong well
there's something wrong in the domestic
relationship there
the bargaining about who does what in
the kitchen hasn't been
fought through and so
you have to have those fights to put
things in order and
if you don't then you end up with a
worse fight in the future
and so the reason that i call things out
as far as i can tell the positive reason
who knows what the negative reasons are
is because i don't want more conflict
i'd rather have genuine peace which is
very very very hard to obtain
people generally obtain peace by
sweeping things under the carpet
i have another chapter in this new book
called don't hide things
in the fog and it
that's what it concentrates on is pay
attention to your negative emotions
resentment particularly it's like it's
so it's so
uh informative you find out where you're
immature
well do you want to probably not who
wants to find out that
or you'll find out who's oppressing you
and maybe then you can learn to stand up
for yourself
you